it's a bird it's a plane it's you have
you ever dreamed of being a superhero
what would your power be more power if
you are just three times stronger than
the world's strongest person you could
lift a compact car what else could you
do or not do with superhuman strength be
a blessing or a curse this is what if
and here's what would happen if you had
the strength of a superhero you might
not have washboard abs or buns of steel
but you're a lot stronger than you think
research shows that even during maximal
exercise the average human only uses
about 60 percent of their total strength
rigorous training enables professional
athletes to tap into 80% of their
strength so if we've got the power why
can't we use it all at once because
brain beats brawn your brain is the
governor of your body it's designed to
keep you alive your brain sends pain
through your body when you exert
yourself as a signal not to push
yourself too far because if you could
muster 100% of your strength 100% of the
time you tear your muscles and break
your bones in fact you might not even
survive using your full strength why
else do you think they call it a
deadlift
the world record for dead lifting is 524
kilograms and in extreme circumstances
ordinary people have hoisted cars to
save someone trapped underneath but what
if you could do that without adrenaline
how would your life be different first
of all your body would have to change
drastically your bones and your muscles
would need to be a lot more dense to
accommodate your strength and your
bodily systems would have to change as
well one perk is that you'd get to eat
more healthily that is superhuman
strength is powered by superhuman energy
and your body gets energy by breaking
down food into glucose and releasing it
into the bloodstream so your metabolism
would be a lot higher a full menu might
easily be an entree but you'd have to
make smart choices to give
your body the proper nutrients to fuel
itself for the day protip bananas are an
excellent source of carbohydrates
potassium and vitamin b6 you can rely on
them to boost your energy whether you're
fighting crime or falling asleep at work
but what's the use of being healthy and
in better shape if you can't leave the
house think about it everything we
interact with is designed for humans
sorry but you're a superhuman with your
strength door handles would rip right
off coffee mugs and wine glasses which
shatter in your hand and it wouldn't
just be Flores crumbling under your feet
but likely earth and concrete as well
since you'd be exerting a lot more force
over the same area occupied by a normal
human it would be hard if not impossible
to interact with any object in our world
without destroying it you'd need special
clothes and special shoes but any
attempt to pay for them with paper money
would result in its shredding at your
touch and that's ignoring the even
bigger question which bank is going to
let someone in who can open the vault
with their index finger the other major
thing to consider is pressure superhero
movies tend to overlook this but if they
were real something like this could
never happen once you have superhuman
strength hopefully you'd remember that
pressure is equal to force over area and
then maybe you'd look down at the palms
of your hands and realize that you've
got a lot of force distributed over not
a lot of area so what would really
happen here due to the tremendous force
being exerted over such a small area the
pressure would be so great that Superman
would actually end up going right
through the airplane not exactly the
kind of rescue you were hoping for is it
superhuman strength isn't all it's cut
out to be yeah you might look cool but
life on Earth would be very difficult
and you'd end up doing more harm than
good want big biceps and toned calves go
to the gym lift some weights eat well
and stay in shape but whether you call
yourself brainy brawny or just plain
average remember that you're a lot
stronger than you think you are and that
you can always be a hero just as you are
ooh